the wonderful workshop and that session
uh
starts and almost ends also with scott
erinson
who will talk about verification of
boson sampling devices
all right well uh thanks very much so
when
tamar invited me here he asked me to
speak on this topic
so uh uh so the first half of the talk
is gonna be basically what is boson
sampling uh
you know what's the point of it what are
we trying to do with it
uh and i know that some of you have
heard me give you know talks about that
before
you know but i'll just cover sort of the
the basics and then the second half of
the talk will be
uh stuff that uh we've been uh working
on just within the last year or two
about supposing that you built a boson
sampling
device you know how would you convince a
skeptic of it right how would you prove
to a skeptic that it was
you know really doing something quantum
or something that was hard to simulate
classically
okay and that's the part of the talk
that i just really ties into the
the protocols uh theme of this workshop
um sort of okay
so uh uh so so our starting point uh for
this work is the extended church touring
thesis
which is just the uh you know a false a
very very far-reaching
guess falsifiable claim about the
physical world
and which says that everything that's
feasibly computable
in the physical world you know is also
feasibly computable by a
deterministic or or maybe a
probabilistic touring machine
okay the original church touring thesis
of course you know would just be
would just strike out uh the word
feasibly here okay and you know and
that's a thesis that i think is held up
you know remarkably well for 80 years
okay the extended uh
thesis uh is is a much bolder claim
and um you know as uh everyone in this
room knows uh it was uh
uh given a severe challenge uh 20 years
ago
when peter short discovered his
factoring algorithm
okay so uh uh so one way to state you
know what sure proved
uh is you know rather than talking about
uh
uh quantum computers and some you know
indefinite future we can just say it's a
hardness result
for a practical problem that people care
about today
namely the problem of simulating quantum
physics okay it says that
you know it has no uh efficient
classical algorithm unless factoring
integers does as well
okay so uh so many people would say okay
so you know
at least you know modulo uh you know our
belief that factoring is hard
uh uh you know the ect is false right
what more you know and i guess on our
belief that quantum mechanics is true
right so so what more evidence do we
really want right just
you know we might as well just uh you
know bury the ect you know stick a fork
in it whatever
okay so um so let me um
i'll mention you know you know uh two
possible uh uh
uh deficiencies um okay the
first is that you know as we've learned
um building a quantum computer you know
a universal one or one able to factor
large numbers
you know is damn hard after actually 16
should really be 20 years
right uh but after you know a while now
i think
no fundamental obstacle has been found
but
uh um you know i i argue with people
like every week who think that they're
who think that there is one
right and so you know and my view has
always been that
you know the the most important real
application
of a quantum computer uh is to prove
those people wrong
okay and um you know so
wouldn't it be great if we could do that
using uh today's technology or something
close to today's
uh so uh you know and and there
you know many physicists will say well
look we have systems all over the place
such as high temperature superconductors
or
uh um you know core glue on plasmas
right that are really hard to simulate
on a
classical computer you know and and so
so we already know that the thesis is
false right we don't need
a a quantum you know we don't need
shores algorithm to tell us that
okay but uh the problem is that that uh
um
you know in in these sorts of cases
right you know the physicists are using
the word heart in the sense of you know
we haven't figured out how to solve it
right and you know in fact there have
been quantum systems that initially look
very hard to solve but then you know
amazing uh
uh approximation methods were invented
you know like
uh uh mira you know density functional
theory
and so forth which were then able to
handle those systems okay or quantum
monte carlo
okay so um so so so given any of the
you know examples uh that people point
to today of of
uh quantum systems in nature that seem
hard to simulate classically
you know we always have to ask the
question well you know are they really
hard
right you know is there really an
inherent asymptotic hardness there
or is it just that you know no one has
has
you know has has figured it out um has
figured out you know
uh how to simulate it yet so you know uh
uh
so so i like to put it is the issue you
know uh
is it you know exponential and end
computation time or is it just
o of one nobel prizes okay so
so what we would like is to meet the
physicist halfway
by which i mean you know find some
quantum system
which is closer to uh experimental
realization
than a universal quantum computer is but
uh for which nevertheless we can give
some evidence uh that is hard of the
sort that a theoretical computer
scientist
would know how to evaluate okay which
means you know some sort of reduction
argument or something like that
okay so so that's the first goal uh
we'll have and then
a second issue is that you know if you
talk to number theorists many of them
uh are not at all confident that
factoring is is it is classically hard
you know i mean
uh uh if there were a fast classical
factoring algorithm um
you know yes this would collapse you
know the world's
electronic commerce the way that we've
set things up
but as far as anyone knows it wouldn't
collapse the polynomial hierarchy
right it wouldn't uh you know you know
as far you know
there could be of factoring as far as we
know is just a you know very special
problem
you know it might very well be hard for
classical computers
i would tend to guess that it is uh but
you know if it had a fast fact
a fast classical algorithm that wouldn't
have any other disastrous theoretical
consequences that we know about
right you know wouldn't cause p equals
np it wouldn't cause anything like that
okay so you know wouldn't it be great to
rectify that situation wouldn't be great
to find a quantum system
where if it could be you know
efficiently simulated classically
then something really really bad would
happen you know like
p equals n pi okay so uh well we won't
you know
we don't achieve that with boson
sampling but we get you know closer than
maybe one would have thought possible
okay so so what boson sampling is is
it's a proposal for a a very rudimentary
type of quantum computer
uh which is not we don't think capable
of universal quantum computing
for that matter doesn't even seem
capable of universal classical computing
okay furthermore it has you know zero
practical applications that we know
about well again
but but for the you know what i think of
as you know the
the central application of quantum
computing namely disproving the skeptics
you know it seems like it would already
suffice okay
um so uh so so it's a type of
quantum computing which is not based on
qubits at all
instead it's based on uh systems of
identical
non-interacting photons okay really
actually you could implement the system
with any type of uh
um um identical bosons okay you could do
you could use bosonic excitations in
solid state
uh you could even use higgs bosons in
principle
uh you know but uh but but for now
photons seem like they're the you know
the most practical way to realize this
so i'll
i'll just talk about photons and what
follows
the classical counterpart would be
galton's board which some people have
seen in science museums
where you know it's a very simple 19th
century computer
where you just throw balls into a
lattice of pegs and you you know look at
the problem you know you look at the
probability distribution over
uh um you know outputs where an output
consists of
how many balls have landed in each uh uh
slot at the bottom okay and you know
this for example if uh
uh you know you could use this computer
to compute the binomial distribution
if you didn't in the unlikely event that
you didn't know a better way to do it
okay uh so uh so
okay so with uh boson sampling we
basically replace the balls by photons
we replace the uh
pegs by beam splitters and phase
shifters
some sort of simple you know linear
optical elements
and uh so uh it's been known since the
1980s that uh when you do that
um you know you get you you very quickly
get some some interesting you know
counterintuitive phenomena
so there's a very nice one called the
hongo mandel dip okay which and this is
if you take two identical photons and
send them down two
arms into just a 50 50 beam splitter
so basically like a hadamard operation
okay and then you look at which which
arm do the photons uh end up in
on the bottom okay what you find is if
this were
you know done perfectly um uh then uh
with
half probability both photons go down
the right arm
with half probability they both go down
the left arm okay so
uh the paradox here if you like is that
you know the photons have become
perfectly correlated
even though there was never you know any
um
sort of force acting between them right
you know photons you know at least that
low energies right just you know kind of
fly past each other right they don't
they don't have an interaction
okay but and yet they've become
correlated okay so
like with everything else in quantum
mechanics you know the explanation for
this
relies on interference uh richard is
that a reversible operation
uh yeah sure we could send it back and
then we would get one here one here oh
yeah
it's it's a unitary operation so sure
it's reversible but if
it came out the up the other arm oh
it's a super position oh i said because
i mean i mean
i'm sorry i'm assuming that at the
bottom we're measuring it and that's you
know
but you know but if you don't measure it
and you just send it back through then
you'll just get one and one
yeah so why don't you do this
oh uh well because um
uh the you know the analog of this with
a classical ball would just be something
that you know
half the time sends the ball one way and
half the time sends it the other way
right
i mean a more a more advanced way to say
it is that the beam splitter you know
only acts linearly in terms of the
creation operators
right so you know usually when
physicists talk about interaction they
would mean something that's you know at
least
like quadratic you know and then
creation operators
okay so all right
good so so yeah so so what's really
going on here is this is quantum
interference okay it's that
uh if you calculate the amplitude for
the two photons to go down separate arms
there are two contributions to it like
one where the first photon goes left and
the second goes right
and one where the you know where they go
the other way around
okay and they you know and those
contribute amplitudes with opposite
signs so they cancel each other out
okay that's sort of really what's what's
happening here uh whereas the
contributions where both photons go down
the same arm are in phase with each
other okay
uh so all right so what's the the more
general uh setup here
okay so in general we can imagine not
just uh two photons but n
photons okay uh let's say each one
goes you know starts out in a separate
input mode okay so they all start out
like going down different uh
fibers okay one one photon in each fiber
and then these photons enter an array of
uh
beam splitters like like this you know
so this is what we'll call an
an optical network okay this is the
linear optics you know analog of
of a circuit okay and um and then um
at the end you know we'll observe you
know some number of photons
in each of the output modes okay so
we'll make a measurement
and you know we'll get uh the output
will be some probability distribution
over you know how many photons are there
in each of the modes
okay on it'll be convenient for me to
assume that we've got
many more output modes than just n okay
so
so let m be the number of output modes
and you know
we we use in boson sampling we generally
want
at least 2n output modes and many times
uh
we actually want n squared of them okay
um
so uh photons are never created or
destroyed in this process
okay so uh so the number of output
photons will always sum up to n
okay and we're just interested in in the
probability distribution
um so uh so of course you know photons
or bosons and bosons can clump together
right you can get more than one boson
in the same place at the same time okay
unlike fermions
uh and you know that can certainly
happen here uh but
uh uh most of the time it will be
convenient for us to just ignore
uh the uh the occasions where that
happens you know then this is one reason
why we want lots of output modes okay
uh we have enough output modes we're in
what's called the dilute limit where you
can assume that most of the time
you know each output mode will get
either zero or one photon
okay so let's just focus for now on on
that on that type of output
okay so so then there are m choose n of
course possible outputs
of that kind and uh so what is the
probability of each
of each output uh well uh the the
beautiful
fact which uh maybe you know uh many of
you have seen
is that uh to calculate the probability
of some output state
you have to take the the absolute square
of the permanent of a matrix
okay a matrix of complex numbers in fact
okay
so the way it works is that uh we form
uh there there's an m by n matrix a
which you know i'll call the uh the
boson sampling matrix okay this is just
the scattering matrix that that gives
you the amplitude
the transition amplitude from each input
mode to each output mode
okay so this is just like the the first
n
columns of an m by m unitary matrix
you're like okay it's an
m by n uh uh matrix where the where the
n
columns are all uh orthonormal
okay so uh so now uh to find the
probability
of some outcome so let's say you know
you're interested in the
probability that there will be a photon
in mode two and mode
three and in mode five and none of the
other modes okay then what you would do
is you would take the second third and
fifth rows of this matrix a
so the rows you know corresponding to uh
the uh
the output modes that you're interested
in okay those you know then those would
give rise to an n by
n sub matrix of of a which i'll call a
sub
s you know s being the outcome you care
about
and then the probability of outcome s
will just be the absolute square of the
permanent of a sub s
okay uh you know it's a beautiful fact
that when you include also
the the contributions with you know
multiple photons in a mode
that you you know this does give you a
normalized probability distribution you
know you can uh
it's a it's a very you know there's a
very nice proof of that
okay but uh for us the important point
here is that um
the uh the the amplitudes of each
output configuration are given by
permanence okay and that's going to be
the sort of the
starting point for us okay uh note that
if you know we were dealing with with
fermions it would instead be the
determinant
okay and note that uh as we know in
computer science the permanent is much
harder
this is why uh we're talking about boson
sampling and not about fermion sampling
okay in fact for fermion sampling there
is
an efficient classical algorithm to
simulate it diaz is
known by from valiant and from mater and
vincenzo
okay so uh so you know if if
uh um the amplitudes for identical
bosons are given by permanence and if we
know
from from valiant in the 70s that the
permanent is sharp p
complete okay so it's as hard as any
combinatorial counting problem
right then uh you know putting those two
things together
you know that that sounds really awesome
right sounds like well you know we
should go out and build a device
that uh we'll use um
you know the uh uh um uh that will just
use a bunch of photons to you know
to solve sharp p you know and so in
particular np complete problems right
i mean you know everyone should just
forget about the wave right i mean just
you know this would have you know 10 000
times you know
the the the you know uh the the you know
the applications of you know
of even you know anything that they
promise right so uh
um okay so so so what's the catch well
you know
this was first written about by
troyansky and tishby in the mid 90s
and they sort of correctly realized what
the catch was
uh yeah this sounds too good to be true
and uh and the catch is that uh um
amplitudes of course in quantum
mechanics are not directly observable
okay so yes you can construct an optical
experiment
uh such that the amplitude of some
particular output state
you know uh uh corresponds to the part
to a permanent that you're interested in
computing
like yes you can do that you can
construct such an experiment
however in order to do it you have to
embed your matrix as a sub matrix of a
unitary matrix
right which you know of course if your
matrix had entries larger than one you
would have to scale it down
you know but yes you know you could take
any it's a theorem that you can take any
matrix and
scale it down and then embed it as a sub
matrix
of some larger unitary matrix okay
so yes you can do that but then um uh
um you know then then uh there's no
guarantee that the
one amplitude that you care about will
be detectably large
right in fact it in general it will be
exponentially small
which means that in order you know yes
by by repeating your experiment enough
times
you could get a decent estimate of the
absolute square of the permanent of your
matrix
right and one can show that even just
estimating
uh the if you know the permanent or even
just estimating
the absolute square of the permanent is
already a sharp p
complete problem okay you know i i just
think it's important here that we're
dealing with complex matrices
many of you might know that for
non-negative matrices uh you can
approximate their permanence in
polynomial
time using this durham sinclair vegota
algorithm
okay for complex matrices you can show
that even
just approximating the squared permanent
is already sharp p
complete okay so and yes you can you can
get
an estimate by repeating your experiment
enough but in general you'll have to
repeat it an exponential number of times
okay so this is not giving you any real
speed up over
uh what you know what you could do
classically okay
so then you know the the next you know
reaction one has us to just give up and
say all right well
you know this was a cool idea but i
guess it has no you know it has no real
world implications whatsoever
okay well uh but but um
there is a a better thing you can do
which is that
you can look uh you know not at the
problem of calculating a permanent
but just look at you know whatever it is
that this experiment does
and try to argue that that is already
hard for a classical computer to
simulate
okay so what does the uh experiment uh
do well what it does is it samples from
you know uh well what it does is it
simulates itself
right like i think there was an snbc
comic recently about how like
you know someone's like holding up a
piece of cheese and saying like this is
the best possible computer to simulate
cheese
like behold right so
you know a boson sampling device you
know if nothing else it simulates its
own time evolution
okay so uh or to put it differently it
solves
what we could call the mathematical
problem of boson sampling okay which is
the problem
you're given as input this m by n matrix
a
and now you would like to output a
sample from
the corresponding you know probability
distribution
i'll call d sub a which is defined you
know in terms of the the permanence of
these various sub matrices of a
okay um so uh
so now we can ask okay just you know now
we're not
even trying to compute the permanent
we're just trying to sample from this
distribution
where the probabilities are given by by
absolute squares of permanence
okay so now we can ask how hard is that
task okay
and and once we ask that then um we can
prove
two results uh depending on whether
you're interested in exact or
approximate sampling
okay the easy case to understand is
exact sampling
okay and there it's actually quite easy
to show
that if you had suppose you had a
classical
polynomial time algorithm that sample
from exactly the same distribution
uh that this optical experiment sampled
from
then p to the sharp p would equal bpp to
the np
uh for those of you who don't know what
that means you can take my word for it
that it's bad uh
it would you know it would mean that uh
among other things that the polynomial
hierarchy would collapse
which you know many of us regard as sort
of almost as bad as p equals np but just
sort of
at a higher level up okay but you know
it's intuitively what this is saying is
that
if this were true then um um sharp p
problems so counting problems would be
sort of no harder than
np problems which are problems of where
you just have to find the solution
rather than count the the number of them
okay and the the
intuition behind this is simply that you
know i said before that estimating one
of these squared permanents
is a sharp p complete problem but one
can show that if you had
a fast classical algorithm
for boson sampling then you could use
a known technique and complexity theory
namely approximate counting
to approximate that permanent in
randomized polynomial time that's bpp
with an np
oracle okay um just use these universal
hash functions to do it
so so then you you would get this
collapse okay so if we believe that you
know
that these you know that the sort of
hierarchy of complexity classes looks
anything like we think it does
then there cannot be a fast classical
algorithm to do
to do bows on sampling
for yeah time but randomized for it oh
sure that's fine
oh i mean in fact in fact you know i
mean i mean because it's for a sampling
problem
you know only a randomized algorithm
even makes sense in the first
is so does place imply them then if bqp
is in bpp then this confusion okay
that's
that's a very good question the answer
is no it does not imply that and the
reason is that
b q p is defined as a class of decision
problems
right and uh and so we're not getting
that you know
if you could solve all the be the
quantum resolvable decision problems
classically
you know then polynomial hierarchy would
collapse
right where you know it's very it's
crucial for this result
that we're switching attention to sample
to a sampling problem
okay so we do get to if all the quantum
sampling problems
you know were solvable by a rand by an
efficient randomized algorithm then yes
the polynomial hierarchy collapses
okay i should mention that that that
implication was observed
independently of us by bramner jose and
shepard
okay that somehow means that we cannot
sample
well you it'd be it says that um you
know we we don't expect to be able to
sit
it's an interesting point actually we do
get the implication
that we don't expect to be able to
simulate an arbitrary quantum
sampling process in in you know using
emily and oracle for bqp
decision problems okay but if you have
an actual physical quantum computer
that's not just an oracle for bqp
decision problems
you can also use it to solve sampling
problems
right so that's you know you so one
could argue that that's really the more
relevant thing anyway
okay but you know but in fact you know a
formal you know
implication that we get is that if um
let me think if uh all the uh uh quantum
sampling problems could be reduced to
decision problems
then p to the sharp p uh would would
be contained in bpp to the np to the bqp
i'll let you be the judge of whether
that's you know plausible or not
uh yes in fact we can i mean then we'll
get if we did we'd get p to the sharp p
would equal b p p to the n p to the n
but fine yeah
in fact yes you know you can say you
know if uh
boson sampling you know we're solvable
even in bpp with an
oracle for any level of the polynomial
hierarchy
then the polynomial hierarchy would
collapse
so yeah so you even get a form of
evidence that you know that
you know quantum computing you know is
you know can't be simulated in ph
right again if you switch attention to
sampling problems
okay so now the you know the more sort
of
physically relevant thing to talk about
is what if you're only sampling
approximately
okay because you know any experiment is
going to have imperfections
and so uh uh you know photons will get
lost and the
uh beam splitters won't be aligned
perfectly you know and so forth
so it's you know it's very uh unfair
to require you know your classical
simulation to be perfect
okay so you know a more reasonable
requirement is to say that
um you know we should be our classical
sampler should be able
to sample from any distribution that has
small
variation distance from uh the uh
the from the see you know from the ideal
distribution
okay so let's say we should be able to
sample from something that has variation
distance at most epsilon
from d sub a and time polynomial and
m and n and one over epsilon okay so so
now we can say is that
you know still a hard problem right and
this was really
you know um we knew from the beginning
this was sort of the real question
and and this to tell you the truth is
really what led us to be interested in
bosons in the first place
okay uh because we knew that boson
amplitudes were permanent
and we knew that the permanent was not
only sharp p complete
but sort of robustly sharp p complete
right that you know it has
worst case average case equivalents and
things like that
okay uh so so that was you know really
our motivation
um you know now the fact that bosons
actually exist in physical reality was a
very nice bonus for us
uh yeah mario yeah
what the approximate sampling well no i
mean the approximate sampling this i
think
you know is is what you you could do
with
uh i mean you you you so certainly with
a
you know uh boson sampling can be
simulated
you know by a qubit-based quantum
computer okay again
not by an oracle for bqp decision
problems
but that's not the relevant thing anyway
okay
then you would get some magnificent
hardness result for
being filipino yes you cannot
since you can't stimulate it uh
no no okay okay there's a couple things
to unpack here the first is that
uh we're we're talking about sampling
problems okay we've
we've forgotten about decision problems
here right just forget about that okay
the second point
okay and this is this is a you know an
important point for the complexity
theorists here
that we're not actually giving um a
reduction so we're not actually showing
that
the you know the sampling task is sharp
p
hard you know under bpp to the np
reductions
and the reason why we're not showing
that is that the whole result
relies on the assumption that you have a
classical
sampling algorithm right in order to do
this approximate counting
you need the hypothesis that you had a
classical sampling algorithm right so
it's not enough
that you just have some black box that
outputs
samples from the boson sampling
distribution
if you want to you know solve a sharp p
problem in bpp to the np
rather you need to control the random
bits that this device is using
right so like once you once you fix the
random bits that this device
is using then it has to always produce
the same output
okay so that would be the case if you
had a classical algorithm to simulate
boson sampling but it's not necessarily
the case you know if you just have a
like a quantum device for boson okay
yeah um just regarding the
eqp yeah yeah
it seems that if you have like bpp would
have those on top of oracle
yeah that you can simulate that would be
keep getting those uh
oh yeah absolutely uh you absolutely can
so yeah any decision problem
yeah yes that's correct that's
absolutely right
yep yeah so it's not hard to show that
this setup you know this linear optical
setup can be simulated in the standard
quantum circuit model
okay that's an easy observation okay
okay you know but probably not vice
versa right
okay so now you know at this point okay
so so our better theorem says that even
if you had an approximate sampler
that would already uh imply that you
could estimate the permanent of
x with high probability where x is a
matrix
of independent gaussian entries okay so
that's
you know a little bit and you could do
so in bpp to the np
okay so this is a little bit of a
weirder consequence okay now our
conjecture
is that this problem estimating the
permanent of a gaussian matrix
is already sharp p complete okay and if
it is then we would get you know the
same situation here
we would get that even a fast classical
algorithm for approximate boson sampling
would collapse the polynomial hierarchy
okay so now what's what's known
what we can prove is that um uh to
to exactly compute most matrices
over the gaussian distribution or even
to say oh like a one percent of them
is a sharp complete problem okay that's
known or you know this we can prove
right by a small modification of of
known results
this is what the random
self-reducibility of the permanent that
i was mentioning before
okay and then the other thing that's
known is that to approximate the
permanent of an arbitrary matrix as a
sharpie complete problem
so all the one would merely need to
combine
approximation and average case you know
in the same
sharpie completeness result but you know
that's the thing that we we
don't know how to do as of yet okay
but it's a great problem i think for for
uh classical complexity theory
okay so you know so the upshot is that
you know compared to say
shore's algorithm we get different and
arguably stronger evidence
that a weaker physical system can do
something which is classically hard
of course we give up when it's having
any practical application
yeah problem that you have is the
the self-reducibility maps maps these
matrices to general matrices and then
you can't control
yeah a particular problem yes
right so i mean you know you want to do
so like like over
a finite field right you use the fact
that you have a uniform distribution
or made for matrices over a finite field
and then you can do
you know polynomial interpolation right
and it just
you know you have you have the exact
values for a bunch of you know
sample points and then you get the exact
value for your target point
okay so now you can try doing the same
thing and
you know and actually something like
that works under the gaussian
distribution right
you take a bunch of matrices under
gaussian distribution right
you suppose you can compute the
permanence of most of them right then
you
pick a bunch of matrices that lie along
some line intersecting
you know the matrix you care about you
get the permanence of those
matrices and then you interpolate okay
you can do all of that
but now suppose that your estimates of
these um
you know interpolating points are noisy
okay
then the problem is that polynomial
interpolation is not stable with respect
to those errors
okay that's the problem problem is that
is that uh
you know that whatever small errors you
have here could blow up to a huge error
in your you know in your estimate of the
permanent of the matrix you care about
uh yeah yep yeah and we can give
arguments that this problem is sort of
inherent
and you know it sort of it follows from
the fact that you know the class of
polynomials is
closed under linear combination
basically okay so
so any set of interpolating functions
that's you know closed
under arbitrary linear combinations is
going to have this problem
uh we can we can show that okay so so
you're going to need
some different way of showing random
self-reducibility you know i think
okay yeah
okay so um okay so so you know a year or
two ago uh
okay so you know you know of course our
starting point was just you know from
complexity theory to sort of
try to get you know evidence that uh you
know that if you could
simulate quantum mechanics classically
that this would mean you would collapse
the polynomial hierarchy or something
like that
okay but you know as i mentioned boson
sampling also
you know has the feature that it sort of
um you know uh
immediately suggests uh a neat
experiment that one could try to do
which is you know just send a bunch of
photons through a beam splitter network
and you know and see if you know the
results agree with the predictions of
quantum mechanics okay and
you know and see if you can do this for
as many photons as you can
okay if you can do it with n photons
then you know you're
you're doing an experiment where the you
know the output probabilities are going
to be
given by permanence of n by n matrices
okay and
uh you know if um if n you know gets
large you know 20 or 30 then you know
then that starts being
kind of cool right uh that uh you know
and arguably you're doing something
faster than you know you would be
simulating it classically
okay so um what's been done so far uh
well is uh uh you know this experiment
with three or four photons
okay uh so um you know it's been
experimentally checked
now you know as of you know a year ago
that the amplitudes for
three photon processes are indeed given
by three by three
permanence okay and uh and in some
special cases for you know
uh four photons also okay uh
so you know there were four experimental
groups that uh
uh um that you know released these
results around the same time
this is a publicity photo from one of
them i don't know exactly what the guy
is doing
uh but uh the uh um
we're still in the regime or the number
of experiments
yeah yes uh we're still
uh this is actually from the brisbane
group and i actually
you know uh uh sort of consulted with
them so they added me to their to their
to their paper but i was not
i was never within 10 000 miles of their
lab while they were doing this
okay so uh um
so yeah so the number of experiments is
still greater than or equal to the
number of photons
you know so uh so what is the difficulty
in scaling this up why haven't you know
the
quantum optics people done it with with
30 photons yet
okay well uh the uh the central
difficulty is that
you know you need all n photons to
arrive at your photo detectors at the
same time
okay that's the only way that you're
going to observe an end photon you know
interference effect
okay so uh so you know and that's that's
really what makes this so
tech you know technologically demanding
yeah
oh at the detectors at the detectors uh
so um you know because well i mean i
mean you need your
your sum to involve you know a
contribution from
all you know n factorial terms if the
photons arrive at different times
then they effectively become
distinguishable particles
okay they uh then you know then there
are
their time of arrival can be used as
something to distinguish them with
i mean so you know so basically you need
excellent alignment
you know and uh so um
so so you know there are two ways to do
that one would be if you had
super duper reliable you know single
photon sources
okay unfortunately those don't exist yet
you know there's no
it doesn't seem like there's a
fundamental physical obstacle to them
but you know we don't have them
okay uh you know where the second thing
you can do is you can just keep trying
over and over until all n
photons happen to arrive at the same
time okay this is
post-selection okay and this is
generally what's done in practice you
know in any of these quantum optics
experiments
okay but the issue now is it's obvious
that you know the more photons you know
if you have have n photons
then the probability that they'll all
you know um
arrive at you know at the time you want
was going to
fall off exponentially with n okay so
uh so so then you know you have an
obvious scalability
problem okay now
uncertainty about when they are going to
arrive
you have some coincidence which is yeah
yeah yeah that's that i mean i mean
that's the way i think about it i mean
yeah and you can get
you know people have written papers
getting much more sophisticated about
modeling that you know the error and you
know model
modeling the uh you know the the loss of
alignment
right but it's but uh um yeah the way i
think about it is just that they arrive
at different times than their
distinguishable particles
but presumably they do you know but
there's a it's
it's more like there's a superposition
of times when they yes
that's right that's right yeah so right
so like
for example you know if you're output
where we're a coherent state right it's
a superposition of different photon
numbers but
you know that's actually no good for us
right so yeah articles
about this than than papers about this
but
there are these things that stop uh
photons right you can talk and wait for
can you yeah yeah so there's what's
called optical memory and in fact there
is a proposal by jeremy o'brien's group
uh and uh um in brisbane right to build
what are called what would be called
optical multiplexers
okay so you could try to you know within
optics just implement
logic where you just keep a photon you
know circling around
until it's time for it to go okay and in
this way you could hope to just reliably
get and photons out all at once
uh you know this technology again you
know hasn't
you know hasn't been demonstrated yet it
is a concept that's out there
yeah yeah if you have
probabilistic heralded sources yeah they
probably all do
why can't you select on those photons
being emitted
just select on
yeah well okay so you want to avoid
doing a post selection where you have to
throw out
all but an exponentially small fraction
of the runs okay however i think you
know you are hinting towards something
that
actually does work and which was a you
know exciting
recent idea that came out of some of the
experimental groups and that uh
um you know we were kicking ourselves
for not thinking of i did give it a name
i call it scattershot bs
okay so um you know the idea with the
scatter shot approach
well it's sort of sort of like what i
think you were saying which is that
you know if you have a bunch of
non-deterministic sources but they're
heralded
so this is the kind of source that
exists today what's called the
spontaneous parametric down conversion
or spdc source
what you can do is you know you don't
know when it's going to shoot out a
photon
but you know that whenever it does it's
also going to shoot out another photon
in the
in the opposite direction right so so
now
uh you can um what you can do is you
know just have a giant array
of spdc sources right and let's say that
in any given run
you know out of the 200 sources you know
maybe 10 are gonna
you know spit out a photon okay but as
long as you know which 10 those are
then you're fine because then you're
just going to take whichever 10
happened to emit a photon and just
define those as your input states
right and so now what you're doing is
you're solving this you know
with standard boson sampling you were
sampling from a distribution where
you know you fixed the input and what
was uncertain was just the output
state right now we're sampling from a
distribution where the input
and the output are both you know unknown
to us in advance
right but you know that all that means
is that inst
you know we're sampling from you know
over arbitrary
and by n sub matrices of our unitary
matrix right where both the rows and the
columns
can vary okay and under exactly the same
assumptions that ordinary boson sampling
is hard
you know this scattershot boson sampling
problem we can also show is hard
right so there's not even any sort of
loss in computational hardness here
okay so so this you know this uh
seems to solve you know the problem of
you know not having deterministic single
photon sources
there are still many other problems with
scaling okay there's still the problem
that
you need reliable photo detectors you
know you need uh
uh you need to uh limit your unheralded
you know photon losses
okay but you know i think that this
should make it feasible to do
uh you know 10 or 20 uh photons with
current technology
uh yeah so you are trying to say that
they are approximate
to approximately this problem is going
to be yes
um
it can be any distribution whatsoever is
you know that has
variation distance at most epsilon from
the right distribution okay so that so
that's the error model here so
is it any easier if you just say that i
know that this problem is hard
to do with exactly but now i have not
always because
you know actually right
actually if the noise is random then
then we're then then things are much
easier for us
yeah yeah
well i mean the the the issue is that
many people
say that well even just assuming that
you're at most epsilon away in variation
distance that's already an extremely
strong assumption
right because you know what what the
skeptics want to assume is that you know
you're just going to lose photons and
you're going to you know be you know
close to one away in in
in you know in in in in
in in variation distance okay
well because you know they're skeptics
okay well so you know okay matt yeah
um
in which that statement can be made
robust
or i mean presumably they don't mean
literally at exactly the same time yeah
but what it means is like within
you know so so it depends on the
wavelength of the photons right but it
has to be like
within you know less than one photon
wavelength or you know
close enough that you get the
interference you know and yes you can
make that more breakfast
but but at least like for for
experiments they could do like three
photonics because
you can test cases where they arrive
like noticeably far apart
and then your computer outputs the wrong
answer yeah
and then when they arrive sort of
unnoticeably i mean so close together
you don't notice your computer gets the
right answer yeah
so there's that there's at least some
like physical threshold
yeah um yeah yeah i mean there's a way
of calibrating it okay
so yeah so it seems to me the error
model is something for you to you know
it's
because the skeptics are only concerned
with
what you eventually output you know so
however you manage to compute it
right if you if you say well i set up
the experiment this way it actually
computed the permanent for me that's
that's what the skeptics are concerned
with the error model comes in
and you're saying look if i were to set
up this experiment
do i have a reasonable chance of
actually getting the output that i that
i wish to get
uh yeah okay but so what we can show is
that under this error model where you
only lose epsilon and variation distance
you know you are solving something for
which we can make a hardness argument
okay this is the result that we found no
but i think
um yeah question was would it be
reasonable
yeah for you to make a make a different
error model yeah where the
errors are random and if that's if
that's good enough to predict
what the apparatus would
yeah look if someone can uh can can do
that and they you know
uh uh all right i'll have to think about
it more often
okay uh you know so yeah i mean i mean
we've been thinking almost entirely only
about you know more severe error models
than this
right because that's what's you know
probably relevant in practice
so i regret that because people had so
many questions i didn't get to say
anything whatsoever about verification
of boson sampling
but maybe since you have a lot of
questions maybe you do
say a little bit about oh and then we
have no questions about that
okay all right all right uh well well uh
since the chair has given me permission
let me uh say something about
verification of uh
um okay so so you know
as we've sort of been alluding to there
is a you know another crucial difference
here from say the factoring problem
okay which is that you know even
verifying the output of a claimed boson
sampling device
could itself be a hard problem okay uh
because you know the obvious way to
verify
would be to you know look at the outputs
calculate the permanence of the
associated sub matrices
and then check that these you know
permanents are sort of larger than
average you know in the way that you
would expect if you were doing boson
sampling
right this would be sort of the obvious
test that you could do
on the output uh but you know
calculating the permanent you know our
whole starting assumption was that this
is hard for a classical computer
right so uh okay so you know and there
was a recent paper by gogolin and izard
at all
that sort of repeated this point you
know which you know we had also made in
our original paper you know they also
said a bunch of other stuff that was
just totally wrong like that
you know the output is like of a even an
ideal device looks just like the uniform
distribution
okay um but you know but let's let's
just consider
this this point about verification you
know because it is a real issue
so what are our responses to it um
you know i mean the obvious response is
to say well you know who cares
because you could always just focus on
the regime of 20 or 30 photons
right and this is a regime where yes you
can calculate the permanent
classically of a 20 by 20 or a 30 by 30
matrix
right so you can check the answer but
you know with even with 30 photons it
sort of starts taking longer to do it
classically
than the experiment took okay so you
you're getting interesting evidence that
the experiment is
you know in some sense doing something
faster okay so
um okay now but now you know in our our
we wrote a response to this um um
goggle and at all where we we developed
a second answer uh
to this to this issue which is that
suppose you do care okay suppose
hypothetically that you were to do boson
sampling with
a thousand photons right and you know
then
you know how could you verify the output
okay well we can't you know we don't
know how to definitively prove that
you're doing boson sampling
and nothing else but if you
tell us your null hypothesis so if you
specify
what you think is going on instead then
for you know
a large class of you know important null
hypotheses
we can in classical polynomial time
distinguish boson sampling from that
null hypothesis
okay so if you treat this like ordinary
science where you know you're not trying
to prove your theory but you're trying
to rule out
you know the alternatives that people
propose then we can actually do pretty
well okay
so you know first of all um you know we
can consider
the izard at all question or you know
which is
is the output of a boson sampling device
just like the uniform distribution
okay and you know the intuitively the
answer is no
uh not at all because you know think
about the permanent of a of an n by n
complex matrix okay it's a sum of you
know exponentially many contributions
n factorial right almost all of them
will tend to cancel
each other out you know on average okay
and so you get a little residue that's
left over
but that little residue is sometimes
larger and sometimes smaller
okay and so you know indeed you know the
the probability is we'll have
fluctuations in them
right they won't they won't all be the
same and so
you know we we first you know we we can
prove that by matlab
you know here's uh um here's you know if
all the
you know probabilities were uniform then
you would get this spike here
okay and here's what the actual
histogram of probabilities looks like
you can see that it's not that spike
okay but you know just to reassure the
skeptics you know
we we proved as a rigorous theorem that
you know that this is not
uh the uniform distribution
what if you had like a thousand yeah
don't you need to do the 1000
uh no absolutely not um oh okay okay i
mean if
if this was all you knew then yes
however i have a next slide
okay and the next slide tells you how in
classical pub
even there is a classical polynomial
time test that you can apply
that will distinguish um the uniform
distribution from boson sampling
even after only o of one samples okay
so this is a further fact that we can
prove okay
now how do you do this distinguishing
well
our way to do it is just to you know
construct a really really crude
estimator that that sort of
is a little bit correlated with the
permanent of an n by n matrix okay such
an estimator
uh for example is the the product
the squared product of the norms of the
rows of your matrix
okay that's a really crappy
approximation to the permanent
right but you know we can show that it's
a little bit correlated with the
permanent of a
you know an iid gaussian matrix right
which is you know
what our sub matrix of a random unitary
matrix looks like
okay and you know we can show that that
correlation
you know that that's there is good
enough to be able to tell
that you're you know your your
probabilities are correlated with the
permanence so that you're not sampling
from the uniform distribution
okay so uh you know so you'll get these
two different looking histograms
in the two cases okay uh all right and
so
you know a more physically relevant
thing is you know a skeptic might worry
well you know what if you know you're
just you you have a bunch of classical
sort of distinguishable particles right
how do you know that your photons are
not all arriving at different times so
that you're not seeing the quantum
interference
okay we now have uh an estimator that
that rules that out as well
because you know you can just look at
like the number of multi-photon
collisions
and that would rule that out okay the
the row norm estimator is actually
useless for
for this distinguishing task okay
because
uh the probabilities are scale with the
rows exactly the same way if the
particles are distinguishable or they
aren't
okay but you know you can use the
multi-photon statistics
to efficiently distinguish this uh these
two distributions
uh we think you could also do it without
looking at collisions
but for that like the only way we can
think of to do it right now is using the
germ sinclair vegota algorithm
so it would be nice if we had a more
more uh efficient way to do it
uh so all right so i so now i just have
my am i allowed to give my open problems
let's have your open problems and then
yeah no questions all right
so uh all right um
okay so the first the first open problem
is you know given a boson sampling
matrix
is there a classically efficiently
sampleable distribution
uh which is indistinguishable from the
boson sampling distribution
by any polynomial time algorithm okay so
is there like a perfect
you know classical it's like
pseudorandomness right can you have a
pseudo boson sampling distribution that
you can efficiently sample classically
okay now here's an uh so this we don't
know the answer to i think it's a great
question
here's an observation suppose you just
wanted an efficiently samplable
distribution
that was indistinguishable from boson
sampling by any
algorithm running in some fixed
polynomial time like n squared
okay then that would be trivial to
accomplish all you have to do is take
n cubed independent samples from the
boson sampling distribution
and then take the uniform distribution
over those samples
okay and apply a turn off bound okay uh
now um fernando brando pointed out to us
that you know if you can even get a
mock-up distribution
that's indistinguishable by fixed
polytime algorithms
and that also has like a large entropy
by using a general result due to uh
travis and tulsiani and vernon okay
which is a you know which is a nice fact
but uh
i think that the main question here is
this can you get you know a district a
mock-up distribution
that looks like boson sampling to
algorithms running in any polynomial
amount of time
uh okay now another obvious question is
can you use the boson sampling model
to solve any decision problem which is
hard classically
okay or let's just say any problem where
you can classically verify the answer so
like any np
type of problem um so you know what with
this
you know a a very uh you know uh a
tempting way to try to do that is to
take
some matrix with a large permanent and
smuggle it in as a
sub matrix of a unitary matrix okay if
you could do that then by running the
optical experiment you would find that
matrix
right but classically it might be hard
to find okay so then
you know that would that would answer
this question in the affirmative
uh but then the question becomes well
what kinds of
subunitary matrices or small norm
matrices
can have large permanence uh you know
and this this is a very nice
mathematical question that we don't know
the answer to
and it could be that every such matrix
sort of sticks out like a sore thumb
you know basis basically just looks like
the identity matrix so you can't hide it
uh so alex archipop has shown that
indeed this is true for any subunitary
matrix with permanent at least one minus
one over e uh and then our third
challenge and this is the one most
related to this workshop
is can a boson sampling device convince
a classical skeptic of its powers
via some interactive protocol okay
uh so i should mention that sanjivara at
all
a couple years ago had a nice paper
where they showed that
the gaussian permanent estimation
problem is
self-checkable okay which means that if
you had an oracle that actually
estimated permanence of most gaussian
matrices
then that that that oracle could prove
to you that it was working correctly
okay unfortunately a boson sampling
device is not such an oracle
okay so can we also have self-correction
for a boson sampling device
i think that's a great open problem
thanks